what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren and
yesterday we went over what Marvel
Studios and Sony has planned for the
future of the Spider-Man Tom Holland
Spider-Man Andrew Garfield's and Toby
Maguire's as well it sounds like they're
all going to be returning in some way
shape or form not only to the Sony
spiderverse but in the MCU as well
however of course the next Spider-Man
film that we'll get in the MCU that's
going to take place before anything
Avengers 5 secret Wars Etc any other
time that we'll see spider man up here
Spider-Man 4 is going to come first with
Tom Holland and according to reports
there is indeed going to be another
Spider-Man in that film however it's not
going to be Toby Maguire's or Andrew
Garfield's so in this video we're going
to go over basically everything we know
so far that has been reported about what
is going to happen in Spider-Man 4 and
we actually do know quite a bit about it
based off of these Insider reports and
some projects that have already happened
in the MCU so if you want to stay up to
date on Spider-Man and the MCU in
general be sure to subscribe and hit
that that notification Bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
we're also doing a giveaway we'll talk
about that at the end so we have a lot
to talk about in this video including
many different villains many different
Heroes and another Spider-Man that's
going to appear in Spider-Man 4 if the
reports are all true but one thing that
you have to know about all of these
heroes and villains being in Spider-Man
4 is why they are going to be in
Spider-Man 4 and how and it actually all
starts with the echo post credit scene
with Kingpin now if you haven't seen it
it's really not that much of a spoiler
all it shows is Kingpin noticing the
news in his private plane he just told
his assistant that he wants to meet with
the heads of his other crime
organizations that work below him and he
notices how the news is talking about
people running for the mayor of New York
City and how basically the people who
are currently running the people don't
really want and the people really want a
fighter somebody who can rough it out
take some punches throw some punches and
Kingpin gets the idea that he could run
for mayor in Daredevil born again we're
going to to basically see this happen
and then in Spider-Man 4 Kingpin will be
the mayor of New York City and this is
where the villains come in you might
have heard reports and rumors about a
lot of different villains coming in
Spider-Man 4 and while all probably
aren't true I'm actually thinking that a
lot of them are because Kingpin is going
to hire a lot of people to do the bad
things that he used to be able to do
when he was simply just a Crime Boss now
he's the mayor of New York City he can't
really get his hands that dirty anymore
at least on the surface he can't have
people knowing what he's doing therefore
he outsources it he hires people to do
it for him and that's why some people
have even said it feels like we might be
getting somewhat of a Sinister Six movie
with Spider-Man 4 because Kingpin is
going to have a lot of other villains
with him now keep in mind Kingpin is
going to be built up to be sort of the
big bad of the street level side of the
MCU so Kingpin might not even be the
main villain of Spider-Man 4 he will be
in it he will be a main villain of the
film but perhaps not the main villain
and over the course of the last handful
of months different insiders have been
reporting different villains like Mr
negative scorpion Craven vulture Prowler
maybe Donald Glover could be coming back
especially after we saw him in live
action as the prowler in across the
spiderverse fingers crossed and recently
Alex Perez from the cosmic circus hinted
that maybe Tombstone or Hammerhead could
be one of the villains as well now again
the question is well why are these
Heroes coming in well one is to do Fisk
dirty work he's the mayor he can't be
seen getting in trouble but what exactly
is the Dirty Work that involves
Spider-Man well you may have heard that
one of the ideas for Kingpin being mayor
of New York is that he would make being
a vigilante illegal and this is what is
going to bring in both the villains who
work for Kingpin and the heroes who are
going to work with Peter or I should say
Spider-Man because according to some
insiders Spider-Man 4 really is going to
focus more on Spider-Man and not him as
Peter Parker and which if we think about
it that makes a lot of sense considering
that doctor strange erased the memory of
Peter Parker from every single person
who ever knew him so a focus on
Spider-Man since Spider-Man wasn't
erased from everybody's memories makes
sense now Spider-Man is probably going
to be facing a lot of pressure due to
this new rule of no Vigilantes
especially since it seemed like
Spider-Man no way home set up a very
grounded Spider-Man one who is listening
to the police scanner going out and
fighting crimes more of what we've
really been used to outside of the MCU
something that fans are really really
excited for so we know that Spider-Man's
not going to quit being Spider-Man just
because a new mayor who's known to be a
former mob boss says that vigilantism is
illegal and this is where two other
heroes are seemingly going to enter the
movie that are reported to be in the
movie these heroes are Daredevil and
Ant-Man now Daredevil makes perfect
sense especially because Matt Murdoch
the lawyer is Daredevil a vigilante who
wears a mask nobody knows who he
actually is very similar to Spider-Man
and that's probably King Penn's main
thing he doesn't want a masked vigilante
out there he wants to know who these
people are that way if they do something
that he doesn't like he can find them
and kind of teach them a lesson enter
Ant-Man somebody on the opposite side of
Spider-Man and Daredevil people know who
Scott Lang is people know Ant-Man is
Scott Lang Scott Lang is Ant-Man his
identity is known the fact that he is a
hero is known in fact as we saw in
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania many
people know him praise him and thank him
for not only defending Earth but half of
the universe during Avengers endgame
same thing that goes for the WASP
everybody knows who she is and now maybe
even his daughter because we know that a
Young Avengers team is being assembled
right now thanks to the post-credit
scene of the Marvels so given our two
superheroes that are going to be joining
Spider-Man I also want to add that it
doesn't seem like they're really joining
him as a mentor that is something that a
lot of people weren't really excited
about they seem to want to have have
Peter Parker on their own he's kind of
had somebody looking over him or
babysitting him as some people say in
all of his films so far first it was
Tony Stark then it was happy and Nick
Fury who was actually TS then it was
Aunt May happy and the other two
Spider-Man now that nobody knows who
Peter Parker is people were looking
forward to Peter being on his own and it
looks like he is still kind of going to
be on his own and Daredevil and Ant-Man
are going to serve pretty specific
purposes and the way that I think it's
going to happen is Daredevil is probably
going to be on the side of mayor kingpen
is wrong and we should continue being
Vigilantes whereas Ant-Man who again his
identity is known might be on the other
side not because the mayor said so but
more about protecting those that you
love although at this point in time
Peter Parker doesn't really have anybody
or heck maybe they'll both be on the
side of telling him to continue to be
Spider-Man because after all Scott Lang
is a rule breaker but again being a
father being in a relationship and
having a family now with the
grandparents there and everything can
drastically change how somebody thinks
so perhaps ant-man's on one side and
Daredevil is on the other side both
trying to help Peter but he still has to
make his own choice ultimately I think
both these Heroes Daredevil and Ant-Man
would help him no matter what as long as
it wouldn't risk the life of Cassie Lang
Scott Lang's daughter but there is
another aspect to this and that comes in
the form of another Spider-Man Miles
Morales it's been reported that Miles
Morales is indeed going to be entering
the MCU in fact Sony basically already
confirmed this they set alive action
Miles Morales is coming they confirmed
this right after Spider-Man across the
spiderverse was released and a lot of
people were wondering about a liveaction
Miles Morales and it seems to be widely
believed that once Tom Holland is done
as Spider-Man after Spider-Man 6 Miles
Morales is going to be the main
Spider-Man moving forward in the MCU and
Miles Morales might be one of the only
friends that Peter Parker himself has
I'm not just talking about Spider-Man
because Spider-Man's going to have
several allies remember the Avengers
still remember who Spider-Man is they
just don't know he's Peter so Spider-Man
still has people on his side but Peter
Parker really has nobody so it's a great
opportunity right now to introduce Miles
Morales as his friend then make Peter
Parker SLS Spider-Man himself a mentor
to Miles Morales because we know that is
going to happen so instead of him having
a mentor he becomes the mentor to a
young Miles Morales something else that
could potentially come from Spider-Man
sticking up to Kingpin is the fact that
he could gather other Heroes to his side
and some of those Heroes could be some
of the Defenders we know the Punisher is
returning in Daredevil born again
there's been reports that Jessica Jones
was supposed to return but due to
scheduling conflicts she could not
unfortunately but since she was supposed
to that means that she probably will at
some point in time and who knows maybe
some of the other ones could return as
well but perhaps they get on
Spider-Man's side perhaps this becomes
kind of a fullon war against Kingpin and
Kingpin with all of these people that
he's hired all of these different
villains go up against Spider-Man and
some of the Defenders and some of the
Avengers we have heard recently that
Marvel is kind of doing some mini
Avengers films before we get the actual
Avengers films like World War Hulk is
supposed to be kind of a mini Avengers
Ensemble film so as Captain America
Brave New World there's supposed to be
some members of The New Avengers in that
film the same thing goes for Spider-Man
4 it's kind of like the street level
Avengers team here which is just
insanely cool to think about and the
last thing I'll say is I know a lot of
people have been asking about MJ and Ned
well we know that Zena is on board for
this film so MJ is going to be in the
movie now she doesn't remember who Peter
Parker is of course and we saw that at
the end of no way home and I kind of
hope they don't make her realize who he
is at least not right away because I
think there is a lot of story to tell
here but also we've gotten reports that
perhaps black cat could show up and Gwen
Stacy which I think would just be
insanely cool and would add a lot of
depth to the story of Spider-Man in the
MCU so Spider-Man 4 has a ton of
potential and just to see Spider-Man
going up against a huge iconic
Spider-Man villain like Kingpin is going
to be awesome in itself but go ahead and
let me know what you think about all of
these reports in the comments down below
and if Spider-Man 4 could go your way
what would that way be let me know
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe to stay up to date on the
MCU and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win a PS5
an Xbox series X some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner picks
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof